Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 24th, 2017. How's it going? Oh,
why are you doing, how's
your week? Obs? Sorry,
the podcast is a little late.
I traveled today.
I flew back from Boise, Idaho. Not
Boise. Everybody. There's an s in there.
That's what I learned when I was up
there. Boise, Idaho. And uh, you know,
it was hilarious when we, when
we landed, we landed it, it um,
you know that uh, the fucking shooter,
you know on the plane, the shooter,
I don't meet with the gun cause you can't
get guns in the planes unless you make
one like a,
what's his face there?
John Malcovich and that Clint
Eastwood movie. What was it called?
Gun.
Is that what it's called?
He made like that little plastic gun
until I get some goddamn respect
and he fucking hung up the phone.
Um, now this, I'm not talking about a
gun. The fucking, the shooter, the guy,
the wedge breaker.
It's like the second they ring,
that Little Bing Bong mean you
can take off your seat belts.
Some guy from 12 rows back,
like runs up to the front of the plane.
So of course he stops right on my routes
and I can't get up and I'm looking at
his dad jeans and he was
wearing flip flops. Alright,
so I got to give it up to the guy.
All right,
you don't have to show that kind
of quickness with like, you know,
a third of a shoe on, was
it? It was impressive.
So this fucking guy who was in the
row behind me diagonally across starts
fucking chirping in his ear. It was
like the fucking NHL playoffs. I'm like,
are these guys going to drop the gloves?
I see him talking to the guys,
see the guy, you know the flip flop
guy looking over his shoulder, right?
It's basically a guy with really nice
shoes and Polka dot socks in first class,
which is where I sit. I, that's I, I don't
give a fuck. I don't give a fuck for,
I'm flying to Las Vegas.
I sit in the front of the fucking plane.
That's just how I do it.
All right?
I spent 20 goddamn years in the back
of the planets. What do you call them?
Not good,
but they just spilled a fucking tee all
over the point of they put anything on.
What are the odds that I was putting
my wallet on the fucking string to the
teabag and in this shit's just going
to go all over the place. It's just,
I swear to God I'm having a hell
of a like fucking four days here.
Okay.
We got damn thing. It'd be little cunty
thing that can go wrong. You know,
first I break my computer screen Ed
and then the tea bag comes out. I mean,
Jesus Christ,
that's going to take me at least 11
seconds to clean up or I just kind of wipe
it up with my sock. Oh,
what a fucking animal.
I said stop it from going down the side
of the table. Don't judge me. So anyways,
let's get back to the Polka dots.
Polka dotted socks. All right.
Fucking gentlemen worked his way up
to the front of the fucking plane.
Or maybe he was born into money.
I don't know.
I don't think this guy was because he
was fucking all over this fucking animal
with his flip flops. Who was coming
up from, you know, the fucking,
the section of the plane
where this guy deserved a bait.
All right, telling you right now,
that should be your guys' goal in life.
You got to get to the front of the fucking
plane and that, that's not a metaphor.
That is it. Literally you have to get
to the front of the fucking plane.
Unless you don't travel that often,
then just, you know, suck it up.
Who gives a shit?
But if you travel at time,
you have to get to the front of the
fucking plane. And I'm telling you,
the only difference between the front of
the plane and the back of the plane is
they just, they treat you like a
human being. That's it. That said,
it's not like it used to be where,
you know,
there was fucking broads
up there and you know,
they'd meet you in the Eastern Airlines
fucking lounge afterwards and they,
you know, you have like a fuck it,
whatever the fuck happened in the 70s,
you know what I mean? Is that incredible
meeting of pubes that that decade was.
Um,
so anyways,
this guy is fucking in the guys who
like, I, you know, I got my fucking,
the free fucking Bose
headsets, the wireless ones
that those postcards gave me.
And then I found out this spying
on you if you have the APP,
I had to delete the fucking APP,
Jesus Christ.
And then I found out those
guys at blue apron are,
I like going down to farmer's markets.
They go, hey, you don't want to,
you don't want to be with these guys.
Come over to us. You know what I mean?
But a bunch of pussies,
if that's what they're doing,
allegedly that's what they were doing.
Why don't you fucking go do that and that
Goddamn Ralph's do it in a supermarket,
right. Stay in your own weight class.
You colored apron cons.
It's fucking hilarious.
As Farmers Barker guy was going
off on him, it's going blue apron.
They eliminate the middleman. He's
like, Aww, hello. You are the middleman.
You're dumb cunt. We eliminate
it. We farmed this shit.
We're going right to
the people. Um, anyways,
I probably just lost the sponsor there,
but I don't give a fuck right.
If that's what they're doing.
If you weren't doing it,
I apologize to everybody that
uh, you know, wears an apron.
The color of my balls right
now. Okay. I apologize. Anyways.
Um, taste bill. Can he get to the fucking
fight? All right. All right. Sorry.
I'm a little distracted.
I don't like doing this podcast on days
that I traveled on my, I'm a little,
I'm a little scatterbrained there
more so than usual. All right.
Before you make a joke, God damn,
I knew computer screen is gleaming.
I'll tell you. Underrated breaking. You
have fucking computer screen. You know,
you take it down.
You never go to the apple store.
Don't ever go to the apple store.
The apple store is like flying coach.
Okay. You're going to go in there and
they're going to treat you like a fucking
animal, you know, and they, as they
put themselves on a, on a higher plane,
walking around genius, right on this
shirt. What does your shirt say?
Says Nothing.
Right?
Like you have no fucking thought in your
head and you've got to go down there
and go talk to those fucking wirey cuts.
Um,
anyways, no, you've got to just
some local fucking place, you know,
they charge you a little bit
more, but you go in there, okay.
And you get treated like a fucking human
being. So I go in there and you know,
and they see the busted computer screen.
They know what the fuck happened,
you know, and I'm not going to
lie to him like, Ah, you know, uh,
I got a little one at home and she
knocked it off the table, but you know,
doing that shit, I didn't do that.
They go, what happened to him? I said,
I stabbed it with my phone.
Yeah.
So they start laughing. They go, why'd
you do that? I said, because, uh, eight,
I'm an impatient person and I'm
not good at these things. And uh,
it seemed like the right thing to do in
the moment and I immediately regretted
it. So now I'm here to give you my money
if you can fix this. And they were like,
absolutely.
You know,
know what's funny is I
always have a piece of tape.
I have a piece of tape
over the fucking camera.
So I don't want people watching me
fucking jerking off to porn. I don't want,
I didn't want to watch people
meet, muttering, walking around,
talking to myself in the hotel room,
trying to come up with new joy.
I just don't want people watching me self.
That's the first thing I noticed.
I was like,
wow,
this screen is really clean and fucking
big brother can see what's going on.
You know, I don't mind if
they can hear what's going on.
I just don't want them to see it.
So anyways, there's this guy, he's got
polka dot socks on his fucking, you know,
smart pair wingtip shoes on and
he's just fun given this Guy Shit.
So I take off my Bose headphones,
you know,
which they probably downloaded the entire
argument. Let's fucking spine cuts,
right? So I take them off and he's right
mid sent to Jay. Just walk right up here.
Yeah, hit me with your bag. What's
wrong with you? What's wrong with you?
And I can't hear what the other
guy's saying, but this other guy,
the guy in first class,
you'd think he'd say some fucking
guy with little soft hands, you know,
never worked a day in his life. He's
fucking all over this guy to the point,
the guy who, who, uh, you know,
the flip flop guy just turns his back
and doesn't want to say anything.
And this guy just keeps going, go.
And he goes, what do you do next?
You're going to push down
a kid, you know, hey,
you might want to brush your teeth too.
He started giving the guys shift from
bad. His breath stunk. I was like,
I've five fucking love this guy.
Fucking loved the guy,
just fucking,
just the entire time it took them
to get the goddamn jetway over.
This guy is just in his fucking and his
fucking ear and the guy wouldn't drop
the gloves, would not drop the
gloves during the playoffs.
Unbelievable. You know, like he's some
star player. Right. And he's gonna,
he's gonna. He thought she hurt
the team fee fucking sits down
the shooter. Man. You don't have wished
would happened. I wished he grabbed,
I grabbed him by his backpack cause
I don't give a shit. If you have,
if you fucking have a black
belt in every martial art,
um, discipline. If you have on
a backpack, it's fucking over.
Cause all the person has to
do once somebody just grabs
your backpack and starts
running the other way. There's nothing
in Jujitsu. There's nothing in a kito.
You just, you can't, you know,
that's why if you watch the UFC
and Joe Rogan will tell you this,
that they do not allow backpacks into
the octagon for that specific reason.
You know what I mean? The backpack,
it's like the gun as far as like, just,
just throws the black belt right out the
window. You know what I mean? You know,
like all karate movies,
like nobody can have a gun
cause then it's just kinda like,
well yeah I can just shoot yet.
You know,
it's the coward way up or the CINCI way
out. Do you remember that meeting? Oh,
you could do it at Cinci.
That's what I was a little kid.
That was a word that just disappeared,
meant easy. I guess it's a cinch
became Cinci I just figured that out
fucking 48 years later I finally get it.
Um,
anyways,
I just wish I reached up,
grabbed his backpack and yanked it back
past into the polka dotted sock guy and
everybody just passed him right back
to his fucking row would have been
tremendous.
You know,
and I know a lot of your young was through
this podcast and I could lie to you
and say that pre nine 11 that was the
America that I, that I lived in, you know.
Well No,
you know,
like you could sit in my house and not
have to worry about somebody from the
Geek squad watching me
fucking rub one out.
You know when the privacy
male Goddamn home,
I have tape over every fucking thing
I could find. I they can listen,
but the kids, see that's the
deal. If there's no video,
it's just like the podcast,
no fucking video and my living
room right now that got, I got,
I got my TV, they got little fucking
camera up there. Not fucking doing that.
I want to look at some fucking pimple
faced, do and play a war of the worlds.
Whatever these kids do, you know, or the
world's waterways with fuck, Warcraft,
Minecraft, mind head. What is it called
as a video game transcended video gamers
to the point that I actually know isn't
it wasn't witches of Eastwick.
What does that,
what does that fucking game that
everybody loses that by when it comes out.
It's not war craft.
Something like that.
I, it'll come to me. No one or
whatever. That's how you just guess.
I'd get out of your own stupidity. That's
such a great phrase. Ad will come to me.
What an, I know that back in the day
when I was in math class, you know,
what is the sine, cosine and
tangent of that fucking iPod news?
Uh, Mr Burn. Oh, it's uh,
uh, don't tell him though.
I, you know, it'll come to me. It'll come
to me now my teacher today, fair enough.
Then maybe I would've have to go to
summer school two out of four years.
I should have gone all three. Fuck,
I should've got all four years.
You know what I mean?
My Sophomore teacher let me off
the hook and gave me a d minus,
and then senior year I was
like, well, what's the point?
What's the fucking point?
What am I getting to a better community?
Yeah.
It didn't make any fucking difference.
You know what I mean?
It's like when the fucking
outfields play in, in, you know,
and then the guy up to the plate,
he hits it over the guy's fucking head.
He doesn't go get it and she just runs it.
That's why I treated some schools my
senior year, not fucking doing that shit.
What's the point when I can
go out and get hammered,
drive drunk and do what you did in
the 80s just driving around, hammered,
hammered. You'd go down to the
fucking liquor store. The packy is,
we called it ain't go down a package,
get me a sex at dote,
we'd go down to the package store, right.
And you just stand there out front,
you know the hands in your pockets looking
as conspicuous as possible and then
you just fucking walk up to adults and
be like, Hey, could you buy me some beer?
You know? And there was no fight. There
was no cameras back then. It television,
it just been invented.
I mean,
and then nobody knew how to work
these things and people would do that.
They would actually like not
even think about the liability.
They would go out and they, you know,
you try to judge like get a buyer.
That's what it was. You tried to like
tried to like pick the right person.
Somebody look cool. You know what I
mean? Anybody in a suit, you're like,
fuck that guy. I'm not asking him.
You don't ask a mom, you know,
didn't ask any women, you know what I
mean? Unless she hoard it up a little bit.
You like,
you then you gotta make the judgment call.
How involved in her life
was her father? Uh, I dunno.
I Dunno now I'm not doing it though.
I'm not doing it.
Then you just wait for somebody a
little bit of long hair, you know,
some fucking shitty little mustache.
It looks for a dirtbags
basically what you did,
someone who would have no concern for
people under age driving away with alcohol
and um,
and that's the way it was done.
I don't even know what I'm talking
about right now. You know what?
As I got these fucking helicopters
in my ears, can you hear that?
Think they're like hovering
right over my house.
They have an a big parade right now
on a parade or a or something. It's a,
the Armenians, the recognizing
or remembering everybody who,
uh, died in the genocide, you know,
you know,
I just realized that just really just
fucked up my relationship with the Turkish
funny bone. I probably won't be
getting any weekends out there for well
that in Kazakh or stay in wherever the
two countries are that try to act like
that. We didn't, we never did that.
Ah, that never happened. Yeah.
Well the rest of the world knows it did.
So you could just sit there
and deny it all you want,
but are you fucking Bernie Madoff?
How long are you going to
fucking lie about this shit? Um,
I actually watched this documentary,
speaking of just despicable,
horrible things to do to human beings.
You know,
I don't know anything about Turkish
people, but I'll tell you right now,
if they will probably scared shitless
of Armenia. It's, you know what I mean?
The fucking tough people.
That's probably what it was.
They got all nervous to some shit.
I don't know what it was.
It's a lot of Armenians in my
neighborhood and I swear to God,
like every other one of them
you look at you like, is that,
is that a UFC champion?
They fucking jacked the heads of shaped.
Every one of them just looks like they
could kick the shit out of you. I Dunno,
maybe Turkey got nervous.
I have no idea what happened.
I don't know how you
could fucking do that.
MMM.
I don't know. The older I get, the
older I get, the more a second.
And human behavior becomes not saying
I'm some fucking sink, but I still,
for the life of me do not understand
how war is legal. I just don't,
I don't get it.
You know,
let, let's, let's,
let's wait into international waters
here without really paying attention to
anything. I don't, you know,
I don't even watch the BBC,
you know, that's what a lot of
stuck up cons over here. Do.
I just want to get another perspective?
Um,
so Syria gases,
some of its own fucking people and
then we shoot missiles at them.
So my thing is where do the
missiles go and who died?
Yeah.
How accurate are those missiles?
Was it just some guy selling
popcorn on this quarter?
A buzz Syria in a Kazakh is Stan,
you know,
and he's upstairs. The
FREIDA X, right? There we go.
Then we're like, oh, sorry
about that. Sorry about that.
We would try to get the guy that
did the thing that we didn't like.
We frowned upon.
We would like to apologize to anybody
at the food court. I have no idea.
Or our missiles that good. I
don't know. I have no idea.
I just don't get how that works.
MMM.
Yeah. Warren's just really, I
just don't, I don't understand it.
We're going to murder
more your people before a,
you murder all people
and then when we win,
we're going to say that you guys are evil,
right.
The only way it is if somebody just
starts with you, if they started,
you know,
then you've got to finish it.
I guess that's how it works.
You know what I mean?
Did Sean Connery make a speech about this
and the untouchables or something like
that?
I don't fucking know,
but I don't,
I don't get why we're all up in arms about
that hairless fat fuck over there and
Korea.
You know what I mean?
I just don't,
I don't understand why this guy can't
shoot off his fireworks at his own fucking
country. I mean, we do that shit
all the time. Who gives a fuck?
What is that fucking
yeah.
Take [inaudible] got a dope.
Yeah,
that's what he's built.
Like he's built like a journal.
He just has like a fucking,
yeah. I these adorable,
if you would just stop with the,
I'm going to blow up fog in the United
States that he, she got admit the guy.
He's kind of adorable,
you know,
I dunno, I have no
fucking idea. But anyway,
so I was watching this thing on Europe,
uh,
right after World War II and uh,
then I,
it was so fascinating to me. What the
fuck was going on that I actually,
I went on,
I actually got on the Internet,
I didn't have my laptop because
I stabbed it with my phone,
but my phone was still working,
so I was checking out, you know,
a couple of websites and this one
website put exactly how my mindset was,
how I believed World War II right
after was like, right. I mean,
I knew in Germany that obviously they
had the fucking rebuild, you know,
obviously Japan. Hello. That was a rough
one, right. I knew that they, you know,
we're rebuilding, but everybody
else, I kinda thought, hey, you know,
everybody was all in a good mood and
shit and skipping down the fucking street
because it was over.
Is this website put at the end of it
was sailors kissing nurses and fucking
times square. That was it.
And evidently it was not,
uh,
in a lot of ways,
like people were acting exactly the way
against the people they were fighting.
It was fucking brutal. If there
was all kinds of rapes, murders,
people settling scores,
mmm.
All Germans that were all around Europe
that, you know, we're not in Germany.
They were getting fucking
killed and sent back to Germany,
couple of little mini
genocides, which, you know,
between people in eastern fucking
Europe, it was just like, Jesus Christ.
And I have to take some of
these, the fucking Nazis
too. Every time I think like,
I've heard the worst thing they ever did.
It's like you literally
can't even watch it.
I just found out something else they did.
I'm going to tell you,
it was so fucking disturbing.
I'm not even going to repeat it.
I can't stop fucking thinking about it.
And then they were showing the Goddamn
Nuremberg trials and those fucking Nazi
consists sitting there with this
arrogant look on their face like,
well this is fucking bullshit,
you know,
and then I'm thinking,
how could you think that?
How could you not be like
wow yeah that got a little,
yeah we guess we got a little
sideways with that plan. Have
the fucking sitting there.
You know what these look on
their face like [inaudible] like,
like this is fucking bullshit.
And I'm thinking like how could they
possibly think that cause their PR and I'm
thinking they think, well if we fucking
won you guys would be sitting here.
All right, what about when you fire
bombed Dresden about that shit?
And then we can just be like,
well you know we wouldn't have done that
if you wouldn't do what you are doing
if you weren't doing what you were
doing. All right, Mister Blonde.
They just done what I told him that
though no one would've been dead.
That's what we were doing. If you
didn't do what the fuck you are doing,
we wouldn't have done what we did. And
then they would say, well, we what we,
we learned from you with what
you did to the native Americans.
And then we would say, well,
you know what? That wasn't us.
We weren't alive when that happened. And
then they'd be like, well, you know what?
You're still alive and a lot of m is
still alive and you're not doing anything
about it. And whether we like, all
right, fair enough. You know what?
We'll set some emotion to
eventually give a mark casinos.
The Nazis would be like, ah, you
know, fair enough, fair enough.
And that's it usually stay in all his
fucking footage of them hanging these
fucking guys. Just a nonchalant way.
They did it there. This is 42 this guy,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
It was like, it was just a board.
It was like a do it yourself,
fucking hang the guy right in court.
The fucking tie. The guy's hands behind
his back. They lay him down on this board.
It just goes like to a 45 degree angle.
They hoisted guy up,
they put a fucking rope around
his neck and he's sitting there
fucking all in them up.
Right.
And then a guy with gloves just covers
the guy's eyes and then they let go of
them. And as the guys slides
down, he breaks his neck.
And the guy with the hands just,
he just moves his hand with the guys
had seen ever see his fucking eyes,
you know, cause they didn't
want to upset people in court.
It's fucking insane.
Fucking insane. And uh,
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
I gotta be honest with you.
I really wish I didn't watch it because
there was this woman testifying and that,
that, that, you know, if
you want to see it, I can't
remember. Remember the program.
I'm sure you can find it on the fucking
Internet. You know, just Google.
What the fuck was bill talking about?
World War II.
I'm sure somebody will find it and um,
you got to see them like, you know, um,
all right. This is just not funny anymore.
All right, let's plow ahead.
Let's talk about something
else. Okay. So I was in, uh,
I was in Boise. This, um, uh,
Jesus Christ, sorry, I'm
typing in my password here.
I was at boy, you know what,
uh, does anybody seen uh,
Joel Macintyre's new show,
Joe McIntyre from new kids on the
block from the movie the heat.
I got to work with Tom with them on that,
that movie.
And he was fucking great guy.
Absolutely hilarious, right?
So I was supposed to do a podcast
with them to help promote his shell.
And I had,
I just completely forgot and he drove
all the way over to this podcast studio
and I wasn't there, completely fucked
the guy over. So he's going to be,
I'm going to be interviewing them for
next week's Monday morning podcast and he
is going to give me a fucking ton of
shit. So out of guilt, I'm like, fuck,
I gotta Watch this guy show cause I
fucked this up and I put it on and Lo and
behold, it's fucking hilarious.
That's fucking hilarious.
Okay. I'm not going to lie to you. I hit
pause cause I wanted to make sure that I,
I said this guy's name,
Joey Lawrence did a guest star.
I always forget those. Too many
joeys in the story. So I fuck,
I was gonna fuck it up.
He was fucking hilarious.
And the guy who plays is a agent is great.
I don't know what his name is.
I'm on the IMD page.
I'm going to fuck all of this stuff up.
Everybody on the show is hilarious.
Jamie Dembo who I also
worked with in the heat.
MMM.
Who else was in Donnie Wahlberg?
All of these guys were just,
it's really fucking funny,
thank Christ.
Cause I was already sitting there going
like, fuck, I fucked this guy over.
I didn't show up. And then I'm going
to watch you showing him like, Oh God,
what if it's terrible? Then what do I
do? I got to sit there and cross. Wow.
It's a great show. This I can actually
tell you it's a fucking great show.
I don't know what network
it's on. I'm going to fuck
the, but I'll know by Monday.
All I know is it's not on the comfy
network, but it's fucking hilarious.
Just look it up. It's really,
really well written. And uh,
the guy who plays his agent is
a fucking beast. Um, kills it.
And uh, I don't, I actually
found it interesting too,
like what his life is like,
you know,
cause it's based obviously on his life
and does so much like creepy older women
wanting to come up and hug them.
Okay.
And now he's got to kind of
just allow them to do it. Um,
I found that hilarious just because I
don't like people touching me. You know,
I just,
after a while I just like,
I so understand how even Dell,
you know what I mean?
Just as people always wanted to come up
and touch him and then like what if he
wants a fucking sandwich
and all those hands,
he just shook all that DNA.
He could literally start his own country
with what is on his fucking hands.
And when you really start thinking about
that, you know, that's, I don't know.
Like my favorite time to meet people is
during the winter when I'm back east and
you already have gloves on. I love
winter. When you're in New York,
you know you can go on the subway,
you can grab on to shit and you
can finally hold on, you know?
Yeah.
Just walking down the street,
high five and homeless people.
You don't give a shit. Right.
You got on gloves. It's perfect.
Maybe that's what I'm going to do.
You know?
I've always been looking for something.
Oh look who's here.
Am I being too loud?
Yeah.
No, no, no. I haven't done the podcast
yet. Oh, it's the two lovely ladies.
Can I say a load of my daughter?
What's up?
Huh? Oh, you know what?
The Internet doesn't work in the office
and I was worried I was going to stab my
laptop again with my phone. I
didn't want to do that. Give me a,
let me get one little smile here. Let
me get one little smile. Hey Buddy. Oh,
she just woke up. Did you just
wake up? Hey, remember me? Yeah,
it is that smile. Oh, are you
all right? She's too adorable.
And this is not going to be a funny
podcast anymore. How are you? Acuity?
We're going to hang out today. Ah,
we do a couple bs. Nice smile, right?
Yeah.
Oh,
sorry. I'm back. I'm back. Um, all
right, let me do some of the, um,
let me do some of the regions. So yeah,
check out our return of the Mack. Yeah.
How funny is that show? There you
go. See that Nia would never lie.
Um, all right, let me, let me read
some of these fucking things here.
Where is? All right. Okay,
here we go. Oh, policy genius.
Life Insurance. Do you have
it? If you don't, why not?
Too expensive or a hassle,
man,
I actually have life insurance now
and I'm fucking excited. You know,
I can't tell you how relaxed I am on
planes now. Now I know that if I die,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
I have rendered myself like just,
I don't know,
I've just sort of delegated everything
out to this point that I'm just sort of
useless.
All right.
Policy genius.com the best online
life insurance marketplace.
The most accurate quotes from the top
a rated life insurance company's policy
genius has placed over $5 billion in
life insurance for people like you,
Jesus Christ.
I want to,
how many of the people are going
to get murdered in that 5 billion?
Do you ever think that
there is a fine line yet?
Now that I have a great life insurance,
have you ever thought about often me?
Huh? Why did I incriminate myself?
Ooh, three in that question. Creepy,
creepy fucking answer.
All right.
Policy Genius is has a very simple user
friendly website to shop and compare all
the top rated life insurance companies
and give you the best options.
They have a licensed customer service
team to help you find the best policy at
the best price.
While you're there,
check out their other insurance
office offerings like pet insurance.
No, Jesus Christ. Just
flush it down the toilet.
Go to policy genius.com today to save
over 40% is there a reason the door is
opened with those doggone helicopters?
All right.
Oh my God,
she just,
she just put my daughter in the little
swing set thing over there. All right.
Now the tone of the podcast has to change.
Hey Buddy,
never seen a kid smile so much like that.
All right,
go to policy genius.com
there's a kid in the room,
people to save over 40% off
other prices for life insurance.
When Life Insurance insurers compete
for your business, you saved money.
That's policy.com. Please
spell it out. Okay. P, o.
L. I. C. Y. G. E. N. I. U. S.
Minute. I cannot do a podcast
with a baby in the room. Um,
you knew that when you met
me. Zero jargon, zero sales
pressure, zero hassle, man.
Life insurance made easy. Free quotes,
zero hassle, peace of mind. Don't wait.
Go to policy, genius.com
today. Oh look who's back.
It's our old friends,
old zip
recruiter. They, I wanted you
to do the recruiting part.
You have to know your wife's mad at you
just by looking at the back of her head.
Um,
are you hiring?
Why do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place. Oh, that's
not enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the
top job sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com you can post
your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click. Find candidates
in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to Ziprecruiter's.
Ooh, Uzi, easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office. Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why old zip
[inaudible] has been used by fortune
100 companies and thousands of small and
medium sized businesses and right now my
listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter
for free, for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] that's
ziprecruiter.com/per
zip.com/bar all right, what do
we got here? Is it only one more?
Oh, beautiful. You don't have.
The great thing about shitting
on advertisers aren't you
get less and less than
it's less reading out loud.
All right?
He looks everybody Helux you're unique.
You don't walk like everyone else. Talk
like everyone else. Sure. Track out.
Fight mark,
cool or sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
I don't know.
Hey, fill it feels good. I don't know.
These guys give me anxiety like I
thought my aunt, my mattress was fine.
This is a classic sales technique.
Scare the shit out of them.
Create a need because it truly customized
mattress will cost you five to 10,000
bucks.
Who the fuck has that kind of money?
But that guy with the polka.sucks stuff.
You know I loved about him.
He wasn't afraid of getting sued either.
Is that on my screen? Oh No. Okay.
Until now. Okay. Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a three d biomechanical
model of your body through proprietary
algorithms as they developed with the
help of the world's leading era and
biomechanic experts. The result,
like an exact replica carbon copy.
Fucking AI robot shows up looking
just like you and you're like, wait,
but you or me, and then it stabs you in
the throat with the fucking ice pick,
but not before your mattress arrives.
You will be one of the most well
rested murder victims of a robot
the world has ever seen the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helux Helix.
A customers report at 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
I don't, I don't understand how you know,
I guess how you feel when you wake up.
How does it feel? It feels, yeah.
How much better I, you know,
I don't know.
30% 30% sounds like a lie.
If they said like 27%
it'd be like, okay, no,
but that's something people would say.
They'd pick a round number. All right.
You know what? I believe him.
All right. And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
That's the beginning of the divorce.
By the way,
your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free and
you and your wife can
begin to slow drift apart.
Like the way the continent's separated,
right? Just, it all starts with my man.
I want the mattress to feel like this.
I want it to feel that way.
And you know how it works in relationship.
You know somebody has to cave,
but not anymore.
Thanks to Helen's sleep,
breaking up marriages for over 30 years.
Um,
your mattress arrives in about a
week and it's shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine,
oh Jesus, Gq magazine. Oh my God.
Get out the Moose to Forbes. Oh,
the banker cuts are all
talking about helic sleep.
You have a hundred nights to try it
out. Graphs. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free
and give you 100% refund,
no questions as whenever I
pictured them picking it up.
I always picture fucking Jesse and Mr.
White showing up in their hazmat suits.
Uh, go to helix. Speaking
of Boise. All right.
Aaron Paul,
he's from up there.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
burr and get $50 off your order.
That's helix, sleep.com/burr
Helen's sleep.com/per.
Okay. Anyways, so let's get
onto, okay, so I was up there.
I am going to talk hockey, but I'm,
I'm trying to avoid the pain. Um,
I'm trying to avoid the pain.
Okay.
I just thought about Carlito's way
it comes to debt. I read that Ad.
Kleinfeld is my friend. Um, that's,
that's one of my favorite
roles Sean Penn ever played.
I fucking love him in that.
I love them with the fucking Perm
and the receding hairline, you know,
he's doing the fucking blow.
Cop comes in,
says all that crazy shit to him,
trying to scare the shit out of him.
He just looks at the cop
and goes, Dun, Dun, Duh.
Fucking hilarious. I don't want
to love Sean Penn. You know,
sometimes I pray for a flood just so I
can see him coming up in a boat just to
rescue me. He's that Kinda
guy. Um, anyways, um,
so I'm up in Boise, Idaho working the
Egyptian theater at a great fucking time,
despite the fact for the first
time in like 12, 13 years,
I had to kick somebody out of the show
and I never do that. And I told the guy,
I don't want to do that.
I think it's a pussy move by a comedian,
deal with the heckler. And that's it. But
this guy was just, he just was, you know,
he wasn't even remotely coherent. And, uh,
I dunno, I offered to pay for his tickets
and all that. I was just like, dude,
you just, you've got to go,
you've got gotta fucking go.
And I gave him like a one more word.
You could just shut the fuck up.
And he's still
[inaudible] I couldn't,
I couldn't even respond to what he's
saying cause I couldn't understand them.
And it was getting, uh, it
was getting ugly. It was
getting ugly. So, uh, you know,
I apologized to the people there
and if the guys listening, you know,
just come back next time
sober. All right. That's all.
I didn't want to do it all right.
I'm sure you woke up today all
fucking mad at me. Um, you know,
when they threw him out, they found 14
beers, empty beer cans underneath is a
underneath the seat. I Dunno know
if they're trumping up the charges.
I don't know if,
cause he was in the front row,
a bunch of Rosa beers cans
rolled down to him. I have no,
I don't pretend to fucking
know. But anyways, I was, um,
I was performing at that theater and uh,
one of the coolest things
anybody has ever done for me,
the people at the theater
heard that I played drums.
So they rented a drum kit and during
the day I got to go into the theater,
the theater and just fucking,
you know,
put it on my Walkman, whatever the fuck
you call it, the iPod thing, my phone,
my little handheld stereo and just
fucking, just rock out man. I had a,
I had a great time. And whoever
the, whoever tuned up those drums,
they sounded great.
The snare was fucking unbelievable.
He's that guy. It was like a marching,
I don't know what the f how deep it was.
It was like six and a half by
like, uh, what's the next size up?
I'm sorry, it was like 14 by six
and a half. What's the next size up?
Is it eight inches deep?
Nine inches deep.
But this isn't a point here
people I'm fucking asking.
Yeah.
Was incredible.
Incredible fucking sound.
And that was his old Ludwig's and
they didn't even have like the usual,
I'm like lugs on them.
Whatever the fuck he called the things
you unscrew and you're tuning up and tune
it down. The drama, whatever
tensioning tensioning the drum,
whatever the fuck he supposed to say it.
They just had screws that were all
stripped so it's got this great kid.
But to adjust it, I had to take out a pair
of pliers that came with the drug kit.
Um, so it was a five piece,
broke it down to the four piece,
set up the Steven Adler fucking setup
that I fell in love with when appetite for
destruction came out.
You know,
when I was going down the slippery
slope of I won as many drugs as possible
cause I was listening to iron maiden.
And then Steven Adler came out. I'm like,
this fucking guy's getting more music
out of these four drums and half these
guys out with these fucking 15 piece kits.
So,
um,
I just say I had,
I had the greatest fucking time and uh,
was up there with the Rosebowl
tailgate legend Joe Barnett,
who fucking murdered all week
and a Monday morning podcast,
uh,
produce producer,
producer said he said extraordinary
Andrew Stimulus was up there.
And uh, we made a tour. We did a tour
of, uh, Boise. When we fuck that,
we got everywhere. We got fucking
everywhere. We went on the blue field,
we went up to the fucking table rock.
We will all over that fucking town.
We had a great time. Um,
so that'll be coming out.
The San Jose one is almost done.
And then I also got another one for
a San Antonio that's coming up. So a,
I'm just going to start
doing those fucking things.
I don't know why I like doing
them. They're fun, you know,
plus it makes me get up and do shit.
You know,
I've been to Boise a number of times.
I never got up into those fucking hills,
you know, so all right. I think
I've avoided it long enough.
Let's talk about the NHL playoffs.
Woo.
Uh,
you know,
you want your team to make the playoffs
until they lose a playoff series,
then you dislike. Oh, that
sucked. Shouldn't they just
not have made the playoffs?
They could just rip the
emotional bandaid right off. Um,
congratulations of saying
this through gritted teeth.
Congratulations to the Ottawa senators.
Looks so well flight series.
I had nothing to show out racetrack
for you guys in your organization.
Good luck in the next round
against the New York fog. Good Ray.
MMM.
And uh, and I gotta you know, you know,
they always do the star of the game.
I mean, at some point you
got to give it to those, uh,
all those Ottawa locals, you know,
there were refereeing those games,
particularly game three, game five,
and even a little bit of game six.
You know, I'm not saying if, you know,
I'm not saying that's why we lost,
but Jesus fucking Christ,
all I wanted was a little consistency.
You know it is a deal.
A ref can fuck in one game,
but you know when it's like
three out of the sex Jesus cry.
How many times did we have to win game
five before they feared at school?
Like two fucking goals.
If fucking sit in the crease covering the
puck up in the crease, not the goalie.
Okay. For those who don't
watch hockey, that's,
I've been watching hockey for 37
fucking years. That's a penalty shot.
Cool.
They have replay.
I don't know how they met our uh,
after further review where the defense
man put his hand over the Puck,
we could no longer see the,
so it was inconclusive as to whether
it was underneath his or not.
So we actually won game five,
despite the fucking Ref's
trying everything they
possibly could to give Ottawa
chance to fucking win it.
Game three, was it the bottle?
You know,
end of the third period.
I can't remember the fuck it was.
Someone on auto just stood up and punched
one of the Bruins in the face and we
got offsetting ruffings.
We both got two minutes for roughing
the auto guy for punching the do in the
face and I guess the Bruin for
not ducking. I don't know what he,
I don't know what,
we've got two minutes for not ducking
for allowing yourself to be punched
in the face. I have no, so it was us.
I was like, all right, that's
what he's gonna do. When I
saw that, I was like, okay,
this ref is like,
it's going to be even strength.
I'm not going to be a part
of this horse shit. Okay.
I don't know why he
punched him in the face.
Maybe some other shit happened right
before that. And this is retaliation.
I don't have time for you
fucking bullshit children.
You both sit down and it's going to be
even strength and no one's going to know
my fucking name at the end of this,
but that's not how it went down.
Cause then in the fucking overtime,
a lot of what comes in fucking
smash is us in the face.
Nash punches the guy back in
the face and we get two minutes.
They go on the power play in
the fucking Beatles. I Dunno.
I'm not even saying that we would have
won the fucking thing, but it's just like,
well, what? Why do that to me now?
I've got to think of that
the whole fucking summer.
Can't you just let auto a beat us? They
were going to beat us. Maybe they weren't.
I don't know. I don't fucking know. But
Jesus Christ, I even thought that last,
that last one. I mean, I'm, I'm,
maybe I'm looking at this through fucking
black and gold fucking colored glasses,
which of course I am. I'd love to hear
what you think of even like that fucking,
you know, they want on the
power play again on some
ticky tack fucking horseshit.
It looked bad, but when you looked
at the fucking, when I did anyways,
let's be honest, when I looked
at at the, at the instant replay,
it's like pasta duck was trying to get
to the guy with the puck who's entering
the offensive zone, Aka a fucking
scoring threat. The fucking auto.
A guy turns around, looks at Pasta,
knock and initiates the contact
pasta, reached out, grabs the
guy and he just sits on his ass.
Two minutes for fucking holding fucking
30 seconds later. Hey, enjoy your golfing.
But you know what,
okay,
what do I do? I mean I
actually, I have no fucking,
I don't give a shit about Ottawa at all.
I go there,
I have a good time. I do shows
they've never done anything to us.
For some reason they decided
to trade shower to us.
So thank you for that to God bless you
on your fucking wing. But now I get this,
but you know,
something is sad is that was
mmm,
I was equally happy for the New
York Rangers. Not Cause I like,
I don't dislike the rangers. He,
I actually liked the rangers. Um,
it's one of the few New York teams that
actually kind of a, see I really love,
I actually love the Knicks
and I love the rangers.
Unless they play in us then I don't like,
and it's not really even them.
It's so we always comes down to the fence.
So I was extremely excited that
the a range is knocked out.
The Montreal Canadian Canadians,
of course,
I cannot give a hundred percent
credit to the New York Rangers.
Uh,
I do have to thank the fans of Montreal
who were in the Montreal forum.
The second forum on that fateful night,
when you guys absolutely
humiliated Patrick Wa to the
point he gave you guys the
fingers, right, number,
that then he went over and he sat on the
bench and he looked at your owner and
I've read his lips. He said, listen, you
motherfucker, I'm never played for you.
Cons again.
All right.
Yeah,
trade me to whoever the fucking Nordiques
are now. And that's what happened.
That's exactly what happened.
He called it and then he went on any one,
two more cups, I believe in [inaudible]
96 and in 2001 or was it 2000?
I can't fucking remember.
Alright.
And the greatest thing ever is Mont the
Montreal Canadiens never won another
cup. The end. That's it.
That's how the story ends as a right now.
Okay.
That's how it's going to end.
I love it.
That dead.
Do you believe is,
I'm literally, I've route for a
franchise. It has six cups, you know,
but we want in 2011. So that gives
me, that gives me rights. You know,
whenever Montreal fans talk about
their fucking all the cups they want,
I just started singing glory days.
That's all I do. It's really obnoxious.
It annoys the shit out of them.
They start wiping the tears
away with their little Hanky,
say up in the front sport coat pockets.
Um,
I was actually talking to Barton and
host of puck off and I was trying to tell
him I was, you know, saying that
I was going to root for Toronto.
So of course then they get the old right
there, Fred from fucking the capitals.
Um, by the way, hey bill, who do
you think's gonna Win The cup?
I think the penguins repeat. That's
what I think. That's what I think.
I think they're gonna have an
amazing fucking series, um,
against the, uh, the capitals.
And then they'll probably face
the fucking rangers. And, uh,
who are they going to face in the
West? Well, who the fuck knows now?
Nobody saw that four game
sweep against the Blackhawks.
And I mean Noah saw that shit coming
fucking people in Nashville,
you know,
they actually got this
such not hockey fans.
They actually showed up for game five.
They didn't know how
many games you had to win
at such a cheap joke. But I enjoyed
it. Congratulations to Edmonton.
Who else moved on Anaheim and I'm fucking
kicked the fuck out of somebody's St
Louis Blues. You know, I guess I
got a roof for the blues again.
I'll root for the blue save and fuck,
they've never won a cup. And um,
but anyways, I was talking to
Bartok, Joey Budnick and um,
a lot of people don't this, um, cause
the May beliefs have not won since 1967.
And I was surprised when I was going
back one day just going down some fucking
hockey history, rabbit hole. And uh,
do you know in 1967,
like
if you asked somebody like who
the greatest hockey franchise,
the most successful one
of all fucking time,
it would still would have
been the Canadians. Right?
They'd still won the most cups.
But a lot of people don't know this.
In 1967 the fucking maple
leafs for only one cup behind
the Montreal Canadians, they are now 10
cups behind him or something like that.
11 cups, I believe. Yeah,
24 to 13 in 1967 the fucking Toronto
Maple leafs won their 13th Stanley Cup to
be within one of the Montreal Canadians.
So that's like Celtics Lakers,
except the maple leafs weren't
lying about any of their titles.
They didn't win one in some other
fucking hockey league, you know,
and then they called it a Stanley
Cup championship, you know. Anyways,
so they went in in 1967 all right,
the Katy is have 14 leaves, have 13
that breathing down their fucking necks.
If they went to war,
right?
All of a sudden they're the greatest
fucking franchise of all time.
That's how fucking clothes they wear.
Good.
And once again,
they aren't,
they won the cup in
[inaudible] 67 the end.
And that's the end of that book.
It's fucking unbelievable.
And then the Canadians,
they want it the next two years in a row.
68 69 then the Bruins one at 70. Oh
God, here we go. This is from memory.
There's so much of a fucking nerd.
I am 71.
The Canadians wind 72
[inaudible] 73 Canadians win.
Then the flyers went back to back
in 74 75 and then they fucking had,
the Canadians had a dynasty 76,
77 78 79 when Larry Robinson beat
the shit out of Dave Schultz.
You know, both of them rocking the
same fucking perm. Both of them,
I believe had a mustache. I
mean, it was, it was 1976.
You watch it now. They look like a couple
of roided up hipsters. But back then,
that's what men look like. And he
stood up to them. And that was it.
That's one of my favorite fucking moments,
by the way. That's as a Bruin fan.
I love that fight. You know, just cause
you know, I don't know. I, I've, uh,
I just don't like bullies.
And I'm not saying Dave shelters or
bullets like you're playing fucking hockey
for fuck sakes. Me. We
do mean to me, you know?
But whenever they would call the bullies,
so it was just something about it.
Like I just saw him pulling people's
hair and shit in. It was just like, uh,
you know who's kidding,
who? I love Dave Schultz.
But after while you went so many fights,
you just start rooting for somebody else
anyways.
Then they want an 86 then they won in 93
they want 10 more fucking Stanley cups
and just, they just disappeared over
the horizon. It was like when Armstrong,
look back at that guy,
you know when he went on,
went on to win the Tour de
France like seven fucking times.
I still can't believe they took
those titles away from it's so,
it's so fucking ridiculous.
It's one of the dumbest things ever that
whole fucking sport is, is on drugs.
They're all on drugs.
So it was a level playing field.
Okay.
That's it.
I'll tell you right now,
if they all at the same people
raised okay and they all went clean,
he's going to win it again.
Right?
He's the best guy. If they're all
on drugs. It was even, I don't know,
that whole thing fucking annoys me.
You know why?
Because everybody
fucking shits on the guy.
But everybody made all
this money off of them.
You never saw anybody give any of
the fucking money back, did you? Oh,
they were so fucking outreach.
Like the fucking cops who run this,
the sport of cycling didn't
realize what the fuck was going on.
You know what I mean?
If someone were,
if somebody you work with,
if you're in a restaurant and somebody
on fucking heroin at the staff,
you know the people in
the restaurant don't know,
but you fucking know
because you work there.
They let that guy when seven in a row
blow up the fucking sport and then they
took it away from,
and then they all kept in fucking money.
That's exactly what happens as
far as I'm concerned. You know,
why isn't Trump go shoot
some missiles at them?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um, anyways, I didn't know what the fuck
I'm talking about. Let me, let me, uh,
let me fucking type in my goddamn
passport, passport, password.
All the screen is just so cool.
I never fucking wiped down the screen
fucking animal. I am never do it. I just,
I'd rather squinty for some stupid reason.
All right,
let's do a couple of questions here. All
right, big eyes follow up. Uh, Hi Bill.
I listen to your podcast.
When you were going,
when you were googling big eyes and heard
you mention the fiasco that occurred,
which you dismissed,
assuming that it wasn't the same artist
and actually there was a fraud involved.
The husband took credit
for the wife's artistry,
which came out after the images were
licensed. Love your podcast. Love you.
Go Fuck Yourself. And by the
way, I am a 62 year old woman.
Oh God bless you sweetheart. Um,
yeah, I actually looked it up. Yeah,
that guy was a fucking creep. Well,
we should put a link up to that.
It's a crazy story.
Um,
my favorite part of that story was,
uh,
I forget there was some big fucking,
you know,
one of those things that
like social lights show up
to those people who are just,
you know, they just did famous
because people, they go to,
these parties were famous,
people are there and day only.
They just have a great conversation.
Okay.
You know, they go in there and they talk
about fucking hot air ballooning or just
something just, I don't know, they just,
people just find them fascinating cause
they can go from subject to subject,
you know, while eating appetizers and
not getting anything between their teeth.
They just, I don't know what it is about
fucking rich people. They are fascinated.
I did say got so much fucking
money. They just get bored. Right.
And God knows they're not talking
to their wives anymore. You know,
they went out and they got
themselves a mattress that, you know,
two different kinds.
Right. Fucking banker.
He probably wants a heated
one. The reptilian cunt. Um,
so I think, I don't know if it was the
world's fair, I don't know what it was,
but they fucking bought, they had all the,
they bought some big, one of those big,
I'd fucking kid paintings in somebody
in the New York Times and one of these
fucking papers that all these fucking
socialite icons want that respect,
trashed those drawings saying they're
creepy there hacky. It's awful.
It's terrible art.
The what happened was they just became
too mainstream and people got sick of
them and they trashed him and then they
immediately took it down after they
think they commissioned her to
fucking paint the goddamn thing. Um,
I mean, what a fucking shame. One
article. It's like, you like that shit.
You like that shit. And then you
walked, you commissioned that artists,
you told her how much you fucking liked
her and you appreciated her work in one
little fucking article.
What did you do?
All of a sudden you were like a fucking
kid in high school who wasn't strong
enough to say, yeah, I'm friends with
that snot nose kid over there. Right.
And stayed with them.
You know, you didn't,
they just stepped away and they watched
dead lady gets stuffed into a fucking
locker with all the goddamn paintings
have to, what the fuck happened?
Her and her husband. I'll tell you
right now. That's reprehensible.
Yeah.
All right. Captain America.
Everybody a Billy Bruce Banner.
I don't imagine you're sending, spending
your free time reading comic books. Yeah,
I can't get into them. I really
liked the way they're drawn the um,
and I also like the superhero
is always have like fucking,
they have like the hottest girlfriends.
At least the ones that I read.
Spiderman's girlfriend was
fucking ridiculous. Jesus Christ,
the fucking titties. Acid legs. I mean she
was, she was fucking amazing. Beautiful,
beautiful God damn woman. Um,
that's why I don't like the movies,
you know what I mean? Cause
nowadays, nowadays they take,
they got to make sure they can't go to
fucking pretty now or also the fatties
get fucking upset.
That's an impossible image.
Check out in the fucking gym.
Do I fucking cry when Brad Pitt
takes his shirt off? Maybe I do,
but I don't tweet about it.
All right.
I don't imagine you spending your
free time reading comic books bill.
But I thought I'd share some news with
you, man. Uh, it was revealed months back.
Uh,
the captain America was actually
a Hydrus by all these years.
Hydra is basically the Nazis.
What?
All right. It was assumed that they
would write it in that he was actually,
he wasn't actually a spy this whole time,
but was pretending to be,
well this month they decided to make
it so that captain America is and has
always been a guy.
This story l elements,
they're adding our trash. So it's not
even a cool twist. Oh, I love, oh,
is there anything better?
Is there anything better
than the, than the fucking,
the pissed off comic book reader with
the direction they've taken the story you
like dead fucking Dolores, Clayborne,
whatever the fucking name is. Uh, misery,
whatever the hell her name was.
I whoop.
What else are they supposed to do?
He's been a good guy for 100 fucking
years and I'm to tell you right now you
fucking comic, but I'm might even
going to read the rest of us.
You guys have I, you know, out of
respect. I'll read the last few.
Okay,
sentences here he goes,
I'm not a staunch Republican.
The fuck did my screen go. I'm not a
staunch republican or a wild southerner.
I'm just a guy who is tired of this self
hating trend once with people hating
traditions so much that they can't stand
a hero. Just being a hero. Oh, I see.
You went in different directions.
This is good. Why red? Okay.
I think you'd like some
of the newer comic titles,
pictures and words and some good stories
makes for an easy stimulating read.
Just don't read Captain America. Love you.
Love Nia. Congrats on the little lady.
Thank you sir. What's your dealing with?
The here is money.
That's why they're doing it.
They have exhausted every fucking
possible story, storyline.
You know what I mean?
Like you remember the Brady bunch when
they had to bring an Oliver, right?
Remember like remember happy days, like
after awhile, like Ron Howard. He did.
They did.
He just left.
It's just like there's nothing left to
do with this character. I'm Outta here.
And all of a sudden funds,
he started wearing suits.
He was teaching a mechanic class.
He became a teacher.
It's fucking hooligan, riding a
motorcycle. Next thing I know,
he's pulling up in a station
wagon teaching this fucking
guy with blonde hair,
how to fucking two and a carburetor and
he's actually helping them with their
problems. All of a sudden it became like
welcome back Kotter. It's cause they,
they were out of ideas that it had run
its course. And I hate to tell you this,
but captain America has run
its fucking course. All right?
They're going to get themselves
out of this. All right?
They'll do the classic thing that,
you know,
it wasn't actually the real captain
America, it was fucking somebody else.
But the thing is, dude, um, you are,
who you should really blame is,
is Al Gore.
He's the reason that this is all
going down because as we all know,
Al Gore invented the Internet.
He said it himself,
he said it himself and he said it again,
right?
The man invented the Internet
and the Internet, you know,
gave birth to fucking Napster,
which gave birth to all of these things
where people could watch movies and shit
for free. Right? Napster obviously
was music, but the other shit,
people go on Pirate Bay,
they just watch all these movies for free.
So what happened was that killed
the,
the fucking 30 million to $70 million
movies. Like they just went away.
So then everything became either super
fucking cheap or $100 million Superhero
fucking movie where it's like,
all right,
we're going to just spend all this
money and people are going to go,
cause they're gonna want to see special
effects in, you know, at the movie screen.
That's what happens.
So,
and they made 9,000 of
these fucking movies and,
um,
there's nowhere else to go with them.
I think they made a couple of
captain America movies, didn't they?
I don't fucking know.
But now what they're gonna do is they're
going to set this up that now this guy
is actually a fucking
Nazi, you know, and, uh,
who was doing all this great stuff
in America? I don't understand.
He was like saving children
while spying on us.
I don't know if they could somehow going
to try to explain all of that shit.
I have no idea. But eventually he's
going to fight Batman. All right?
We all know that Batman
has one professional fight
under his belt and he's all
for one, right? He launched a superman,
so before he gets another
shot at the title,
I think he has to fight somebody else.
Who's he going to fight? You know,
it can't be Lex Luther and
and fucking the octopus guy.
I mean those guys that played out
all right, they're all punch drunk,
spite of man's been fucking them up
for years. If they need somebody know,
so this is the only way to go.
All right?
I would be surprised if Vince McMahon
does not sue them for this storyline
because he did this with Hulk
Hogan like 50 times. You know?
You knew how Kogan was was.
You knew when he was the bad guy.
I love because he would
die the side of his beard.
He would die that fucking black and
then he would have the fucking blonde
mustache, which by the way,
I thought look really cool.
He had a great fucking fool
man shoe. He still does. Um,
do you ever see guy go bald
more gracefully than that?
He just kept pushing it back like Richard
Rawlings and every time he did it,
it was a little further back, you know?
Then he started wearing the fucking,
the scarves.
It always come off [inaudible] I dunno.
Tanned his head up. He looked
great. Then when you say that,
how Kogan went bald very gracefully.
What'd you say?
Yeah.
You don't think so? What's wrong with
you today? I feel like you don't like me.
I mean part of being married.
Some days you're not going to like me.
I feel like that's one of these days.
No,
I don't understand how you're
so loud with slippers on.
Okay.
She just said, that's why I
don't like you. All right.
Princess Kate finds parenting hard.
Well, I imagine when they try to
play hide and go seek in that castle,
it's going to take forever. Hey Bill,
get a lot of this crap. Kate Middleton,
a fucking princess did a speech in which
she says she's finds it hard being a
mom. Now I'm sure she has a busy schedule,
but for Christ's sake she has servants.
I know she doesn't even have
nannies. She has servants. She,
it may have one of the easiest
jobs in the entire world.
She wasn't born to royal tree,
she married into it.
So all she needs to do is not be
a con for the next 50 to 75 years.
Stay married and she's all set.
Attached is a link to her full speech.
You can listen to it. Uh, if you care to
listen to it. I'm not listening to shit.
She's trying to promote mental
health awareness, which is nice.
But did she really need to try to tell
us that she finds parenting difficult?
Huge fan from Newfoundland,
Canada. Thanks. And don't
forget to go fuck yourself.
Um, yeah. I mean, you know,
this is the thing when a kid
comes into your life, yeah,
there's an adjustment period.
So she was sitting there getting fan by
feathers and all of that shit. Right.
Having somebody bring
her old Dagwood sandwich.
Is she sitting on, you know, the, the
Louis, the 15th fucking, I dunno, Ottoman.
Is that a word? Is that a piece
of furniture that is, isn't it?
Or is that an empire? Um, yeah.
And then all of a sudden the kids there
and she has to pretend to give a fuck
about, you know, I think it just
makes her photo shoots more difficult.
What did she name her kids. He probably
gave him some old white guy's name, like
Winston Ebeneezer. The
fucking 19th or some shit. Um,
yeah.
The, I have to be honest with you, like,
that has to be the most boring fucking
life you could ever fucking live. Okay.
Being a fucking princess, at least when
you're a prince, you know, you get to eat.
He kept fucking guy goes around, he flies
helicopters. He was in the Goddamn army.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Goes out. He does shit right tags
out with the boys. He smoked cigars.
What do you do as a princess once
you fucking married, you know,
you broke down on the white horse, she
had your fucking, your wedding, right?
Everybody shows up,
you know,
all the women in the crowd giving you
the evil eye because they wanted to be a
princess. All the haters,
you know, there's,
there's nothing good about that ride in,
you know,
cause it's either going to be haters or
people just sobbing because that dream's
never going to happen for them.
So that's how he sees people stare and
stare and fucking daggers at you next to
fatties and fucking Weirdos like,
okay,
she's so beautiful.
Um,
yeah.
Okay.
I would think it would
be hard to be a princess.
The steam mind numbingly boring fucking
life that you're going to live, you know,
to the, to the fuck. This is when you know
your board is when you promote a cause,
you know, you're so fucking bored.
You have to go out and help. Somebody
was so fucking all set is not what the,
there's nothing to do.
Hmm.
You know, there's nothing
you, we got everything you
fucking want. It's, it's, yeah,
the end game over now what are
you doing now? You got to fucking,
you got to go down to some third world
country and start installing plumbing or
some shit. [inaudible] got
it. You have to do something.
Either that or you just fucking,
you just become like one of
those Dudley Moore characters.
You just get shit faced every day.
Okay.
That's what I would do. Take
up like archery and shit.
I just be in the backyard,
just fucking shoot and stuff.
Walking around with some
fucking ridiculous cognac.
I would be such a piece of Shit,
you know? I really would be, I, I,
if you know,
can you get written out of the will?
Can he get unfucking print x
prints or something like that?
Excommunicated from that. I, that's
exactly how I would do, oh my God,
I would have all the fucking sports
packages. I'd go to all the fucking games.
All right. I wouldn't give
a shit either. I would be,
I would be fucking ridiculously
blowing the money and like,
that would be my goal in life.
Like, how over can I be with
the English Tax Pique People's money that
they're there? What am I trying to say?
The English taxpayers' money.
There you go.
You ever seen somebody like dyslexic
when they're just talking about you?
You think I'm trying to read this shit.
Like always flip words around. Um,
and by all means,
all of you who aren't doctors,
please diagnose me and tell me what sort
of fish oil and I don't need to take
the cure it. Um, that's what
I would do. I would just like,
my goal would be by the time I'm 42, I
want them to, I could easily do that.
I can easily do that. I could get x
fucking, you know, you no longer at Duke,
you know.
Oh, you know what would be great. It'd be
great to, people would actually love you.
I want to say we've done Hayden.
You the second you walked into a pub,
you have no more security anymore. You
just come walking in and now, yeah,
you're, I fucked that one up there
yet pat, you'd be like, yeah, I did.
I had a great time though.
The fuck was I supposed to do?
I was living in a castle. You'd fucking
week. You know, that would be it.
The next,
you know,
you sit in the bleachers right in
the fucking pit at the footy games.
Just being a regular guy,
getting fucking hammered,
eating fish and chips and just laughing,
just laughing at how bad you fucked up
your life and all those fucking sad sex.
They'd love you. Um, anyways,
fat yoga instructor.
Hey Billy. Read Sec. Uh,
I don't know why that struck me so
funny. I mean, I see it everyday.
You think that that would be an old joke.
Uh,
I work out here in La as a
personal trainer and teach
them yoga classes here and
there.
Um,
I've been teaching yoga at this studio
for over four years and I got this fat
ass confer, a manager built, she's
gotta be 80 pounds overweight.
And despite being around
all this healthy lifestyle,
she has done nothing to improve herself.
I'm talking donuts and cookies in this.
I fucking loved this person. Oh my
God. I love both of these people.
I love that you call on a
route for being fat or him out.
And I love that this person's sitting
there fucking eating donuts in a yoga,
a yoga shop. What do you
call it? Studio Studio.
A dojo crib.
Uh,
I'm talking donuts and cookies in the
studio lobby around people that are there
to avoid these temptations.
That's fucking hilarious.
Anyways,
I've kept my mouth shut for years,
but recently we had our annual class
review with a manager comes and sees how,
how you class,
how your class is put together and how
you are with the students, et Cetera.
Uh, this whale couldn't even get
through the first 15 minutes.
She was beached on our mat belly.
She was beached on a mat belly up,
gulping fucking water. Oh, she went
into, yeah, she went into whale pose.
Okay.
Then afterwards she had the nerve
to criticize my class that it wasn't
challenging enough. Oh my God.
And you didn't say anything.
Okay. This is their reason that grudge is
being held. Okay. The, the, it should say,
the reason, the reason the grudge
is being held is that my aunt,
my annual raise was a mere 30 cents.
And I wonder if that
criticism effected it.
Give me that Billy Burger
philosophy on the, the situation.
Love the podcast.
Congratulations on the baby.
It was great hearing her on the podcast
the other day. Uh, go fuck yourself.
Fire Nips.
Um,
Jesus Christ really coming at me with the
fucking red head shit today aren't yet
. Um, I think the whole
thing is fucking hilarious.
Um, I gotta ask you something. All right?
You've been doing this shit
there for over four years. Uh,
why don't you eventually start
your own thing at this point,
you know, get out from that. This is
what, you know, what I would do if I was,
you get an a good grace has been,
you know,
just start bringing a donuts.
I bring a fudge, you know,
and just, you know, I don't
know if the cops could prove it,
but you just killer killer with what
she loves. Kill her with kindness.
Okay. There you go. Kill her with
kindness. Just keep what she gotta do.
Okay. This is the thing about those
fatties is that they can handle doughnuts,
all right? But I'm telling you right now,
nobody can handle fudge. Fudge is like,
it's like a,
it's almost a hundred percent sugar.
It's like a solid form of cotton
candy with like chocolate in it.
I mean it is fucking, you can't even
eat it. Like you'd hope face puckers up.
This is what you do. You come
in, you make a tray of fudge,
all right? You cut a piece
out. This is what you do, okay?
You cut a fucking piece out.
All right? And just, you know,
give it to the birds or some shit,
right? I think sugar's good for them.
I can't remember.
See the good or it kills them either way.
Just give it to the fucking birds,
right?
Then you bring the fudge in this and now
it looks like somebody already took a
piece of, she's not going to feel
guilty and I guaran fucking tee you.
I guarantee you do in the sugar is going
to fuck with the joints. All right?
Then you come in with some
bacon sub sandwiches. You
just keep going. Sugar, salt,
sugar, salt, sugar, salt.
Okay. And just, you know,
that 30 cents they should have given you,
you take 30 another 30 cents out of
your fucking check every goddamn hour,
all right? And, and you,
you put it towards giving this
person food that'll slowly kill him.
There you go.
Or you get a new job.
I Dunno. I just, I just think killing her.
Be Funny. All right. Just your daughter,
a Billy Bathgate's.
Uh,
would you ever disown your daughter if she
brought home a. Dot. Dot. Dot. Dot, dot,
dot, dot, dot, dot, dot,
dot, dot. Dot. Hack comic.
Oh Jesus. Think of the hackiest type of
comic you can think of. And in the future,
she brought him home talking
about how she loves him.
And now he's the funniest
comic ever. Uh, Oh God.
He's got a youtube channel, tells
jokes with the lampshade on his head.
It's Cetera. She asks you
what you think of him. Uh,
you tell her is a hack
she gets mad at you,
tells you you don't understand him
and how he's funnier than you. Uh,
would you dishonor and tell her she
can't bring the hack into what's out now?
No jokes. Leaf. Yeah. Joke. Thief.
He can't come into the house.
You can't come into my house
is a fucking joke. Thief. Um,
okay.
Uh, I, this is what I would do. You know
what? Even even if he stole fucking jokes,
I know he's going to get caught and
people are going to call them out on it.
I wouldn't say anything, Eric.
Cause I'll tell you this, I,
I've seen how that goes down when you
say you don't like somebody that you kid,
like, you know what I mean? And uh,
then there's all those in law problems.
All right? This is your job as a
parent is you gotta Trust your kids.
Decisionmaking all right? They love
the guy. You just got to go with it.
You know what I mean? And then if they
get divorced, you can't be like, hey,
you know, I was, you know, cause if
but why did you fucking say something?
Cause you'd hate me. Um, Jesus, why
would you bring that up? I'm, I'm just,
I'm three months into this. I want
to enjoy my, my daughter growing up.
Jesus Christ. You already got me
picture of being at the fucking wedding.
You know the guy would have some
fucking crazy colored fucking bow tie.
The cumber Bun. All right. I don't
know Jesus Christ. What a way to end.
Um, by the way, uh, how about the Celtic
sound coming back when in two games,
how lucky did we get with Rondo
going down Jesus Christ, by the way,
he pulled off a short sleeve suit.
I don't know how he did it.
He actually fucking look cool.
I think you had to have a cast on
to make it work though. Like he did.
He fucked up his stomach assumption.
All Right Patrice, dear Billy, big tits.
Hey, I'm losing weight yet. Con found this
on youtube almost shit myself laughing.
I thought you'd appreciate this.
Some classic hope you enjoy and go fuck
yourself. I will definitely retweet this.
Um, thank you for sending that in. Um,
you know, it's always great that people
are still watching his shit and uh,
I'm always talking about them and that
type of stuff that keeps his comedy alive.
I know that's all cliched stuff,
but like I was talking to,
I was actually talking to Bart,
Nick and Andrew last night,
a bottom in the green room and I was
just talking, just saying how, um,
just what a fucking,
just still like crater comedy.
Fucking crater. What a fucking
lost that was, man, it's just a,
that guy was so much,
he was so much better than all of us.
It was fucking ridiculous.
And um, I'm telling you,
even in, even as great as elephant
in the room is, I'm telling you he's,
he effortlessly cook.
His next special would've been at least
fucking 30% funnier than that one.
That's the trajectory
that that guy was on.
And I'm a fucking kills me, man.
Fucking kills me. So anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Uh, please check out. Return to
the Mac. The first couple episodes,
it's streaming on something. I
don't fucking know anymore. Um,
very funny and my apologies to
Joe McIntyre for standard. Yep.
Last week I really fucked that
up and he couldn't, you know,
what's the worst part? He was totally
cool about it because no one, no worries,
brother fucking don't worry about it and
all that. That was the worst. I was like,
can at least be mad at me. Something.
All right, go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.